- C'est à Vancouver, véritable
porte sur le continent
asiatique, que la ministre des
Affaires étrangères, Mélanie
la nouvelle stratégie
indopacifique du Canada,
face à une Chine, qui serait de
MÉLANILYLYLY, ministre des
Affaires étrangères du Canada
- Notr
non seulement fermes, mais de
défendre nos intérêts nationaux.
Donc, on ne sera jamais...
On n'aura jamais à s'excuser
national.
- Face à une Chine qui serai
de plus en plus perturbatrice
à l'international. Ottawa
de dollars en 5 ans, pour
entre autres, pour augme
sa présence militaire et navale
dans la région, et aussi tisser
avec des pays comme l'Inde,
l'sisisisie, le Japon
et la Corée du Sud.
du Canada en Chine
- On reconnaîpopopoportance du
reste de la région indopacifique
et on va y consacrer des
dans à peu près tous
les domampmpmpmportants.
- Tout comme l'ex-ambassadananan
diplomate Jean-François Lépine
a été consulté par la ministre
Mélanie Joly.
- On a sous-évaluéuiuiuiuiuiuiu.
- Il salue le ononononon ait
rebâti la stratégie canadienne
non pas en fonction de la ChinÉr
représentations Québec en Chine
- C'est la première fois,
gouvernement canadien admet
qu'il y a ce problème-là;
c'est-à-dire cette évolution
de la Chine, un pouvt t t t t te
les règles internationales.
- Pour la prochaine décennie,
le Cans s s s s s s s s s s s sc
ses pays amis.
- 30 ans et plus après la chute
du mur de Berlin, on se rendecec
ce qui est arrivé en Ukraine,
qu'on va dorénavant devoir
coexister dans le monde avec
puissances riches, prospères,
comme la Chine par exemple,
qui ne partage pas
nécessairement nos valeurs.
- Même si on compte encore
sur des questions gl
comme la lutte contre les
changements climat
Ici Gabrielle Proul